What did you do this weekend, Diana?
Me?  Mmhm.
Nothing very interesting.
The world remains in mourning after the death of the Superman.
They said the age of heroes would never come again.
It has to.
We don't have anymore time.
Something is coming.
No Protectors here!
No Lanterns
No Kryptonian
This World Will Fall
Like all the others.
One misses the days when one's biggest concerns were exploding wind-up penguins...
This is crazy.
Honestly, I think we're all gonna die.
Each of us, in some way, has held back.
Don't engage alone.
We do this together.
It's really cool that you guys seem ready to do battle and stuff, but I've never done battle.
I've just pushed some people and run away...
Relax, Alfred. I'll take it from here.
Uh. D-Do I know you?
Superman was a Beacon to the world.
He didn't just save people, he made them see the best parts of themselves.
All right.
I don't recognize this world.
You don't have to recognize it.
You just have to save it.
Woo Hoo!
How many of you are there?
Not enough.
Do you really think that...
Oh wow. They just...they really just vanished.
Huh? Oh...That's rude.
They said you'd come.
Now, let's hope you're not too late.